here's Andreas aosu aosu with a burst and he
lost the puck behind the net gathers it back
and beats Taylor radish and stolar with a great
save an original pick of the Philadelphia Flyers
in 2012 but you know you can hear the bench
saying to AOS go skate and he does so on the
right side and there's that quick shot there's
Perry Taylor Hall poed up Perry saves it now
Felino Seth Jones fires that was off fors Ling
tapped in by Felino on the rebound Hawk score on
the power play one to [Applause] nothing you you
see that triple ey formation in front of the net
in the classic 131 it hits a body forsling comes
right over to Felino and he just snaps this one
right here parry's in front of the net and that
causes enough of a disturbance there Jones with
the quick shot off forsling and a fortunate break
to go right to incredible tension home team best
record in the NHL by far and the pressure is on
the home team game seven when you're expected
to win Hawks looking for another denado tries the
wrap around Puck was just dangling for an whistle
kulakov at Center met by Kevin Pinsky kachuck
throws it wide it's intercepted by Reichel and
the handoff made to kurashev kurashev shoots
knocked Away by stars and it's Zev who scores
Nikita Zev it is third game of the season gives
the Hawks a two nothing lead they need backhand
pass to continue some flow the first shot there
by Kev as he extended his shift stays on the ice
and the right move and then after his shot goes
glancing wide there through the legs of poring
off the side of the net he finds in the slot
Zev and he makes no mistake whatsoever you talk
about taking advantage of the opportunity look
at that smile on the face Reinhardt po check
Seth Jones Tyler Johnson grabs it Dickinson
threads the needle to Taylor Hall saved no
score Taylor Halls first as a Blackhawk and it's
a three spot in the first [Applause] period I I
mean the regroup was perfect Dickinson puts
this through a maze of players and somehow it
ends up on the tape of Hall and not a good one
for stolar cuz this one slides underneath and
he wants that puck badly and he gets it and
here there's no other option for him to go
to other than on the ice stolar somehow got that
stick Ekman Larsson resets Reinhardt looking for
a man in the middle Rodriguez is shut down by
morazzi Texas experience amazing well keep your
eye on 25 toor he thinks that that Puck's not
quite covered so he sees that barov with that
Long Reach is going to come in and a lot of open
Ice reel dazzling and the play made eventually
by kulakov and stolar is the goalie middle of the
ice and thanks for coming here's the play off the
boards good play by radish to beat Mika there's
the one play the second play and then on the back
hand give kulakov some credit he was going this
way look at the transition in the feet of kulikov
now he's got a cut back on the forehead does an
excellent job of getting the shoulder in Amman
Larson stenland a shot off the post whoa
that was close a long shift for reel foring
hold the Zone Philip Kev 5 Seconds To
Go In the period and a kick save by
stolar Rodriguez undrafted player played for
the Colorado Avalanche last season and before
that the Pittsburgh Penguins cousins drives in
baras save stenland second try Deni it as well
toori Kev and L Stan took his eye off the puck
and guess who Connor Bard scores [Music] yes sir
number five for Conor and it's 4 nothing what
a rer this is KV makes a hack and whack at the
puck it bounces over the forward stick right
onto Bard and he brings brings it one way into
his feet and then fires it to the opposite side
just a laser of a wrist shot once again he's got
the jump right here because the play of kers
a fortunate Bounce by The Stick of the def the
forward of the Florida Panthers and look at that
reaction right there holy jumping kulakov Taps
it behind the net gets it back in the crease up
for grabs and Taylor Hall a two-on-one with Tyler
Johnson Hall Johnson off the post Taylor Hall
waits for as long as he possibly can with that
scrum in front of the net the puck pops loose
and that's going to happen because the Panthers
are going to be aggressive they're going to be
all in and this one here on the short side not
much angle for Tyler Johnson to make the play the
puck is beautifully placed and he's got the open
side and what a save that is by Stoler and Seth
Jones to Cory Perry hard Ricochet lomberg cut
off lomberg back hands it and moric
ready Reinhardt off the blue paint good Chuck and
a stop by the Blackhawks on the shot by Veri and
an whistle can't clear barov emman Larson ver
HEI 36 seconds to go and Florida scores on the
power play Hawks had a chance to get it out
to his an whistle on the boards couldn't do
so and then this shot here I don't know if
Reinhardt tipped it or not emman Larson lets
this one rip right there and yes it was tipped
by Reinhardt he gets the shaft of the stick on
that one it goes underneath the bar and in it's
a flutterer right there and it definitely changes
directions but a chance to get it out when
you've got no gas in the tank whatsoever
for hey circles around and here's Oliver emman
[Applause] Larsson Matthew kachuck forsling oh
it's loose and it's off the post no goal wow
and out and and you can see how this Puck is
bouncing there and the angle of his stick caused
that puck to bounce up a little too H Carry On
The Board battle [Applause] Reinhardt forsling
off the glove of mazic and he covers up no the
rebound was stopped by morazzi but the puck
still in play mahura balinskis a fired shot
from bhagi rebound kachuck couldn't get a clean
look another great save by morazzi mahura for
haggi it's kachuck and it it's it kachuck scores
and it's 4-2 tell you what there's some life here
on the Panthers bench that puck crossed the
goal line and they all jumped up into the air
kachuck had a number of good chances in this game
morazi's been I mean he's been incredible in this
game Panthers are forced him to go east west post
to post and here this puck just dribbles back to
his left after Veri with that sneak sneaky shot
it goes off the leg of kachuk the goal tender
moric there's no way to control that and then
the Long Reach there of kachuck just jams at
home Ean Larson blocked by either radish
or Donado Donado got her in the boot Kev he
scores 52 Hawks hit Ryan Donado more than
it did rtis but both putting their bodies
on the line to allow cev to jump on that loose
Pucket fired into the empty net and going into
a difficult backto back this weekend
Florida Saturday New Jersey Sunday the
Hawks grab two points and officially put
the bitter taste of that lost to Arizona
on Monday behind them great bounceback win
for the Hawks tonight great bounceback win